[Música]
con nuestro primer invitado del día
vamos a analizar el Por qué la energía
nuclear cobra un nuevo protagonismo a
raíz de la crisis energética que golpea
sobre todo a Europa por esta guerra en
Ucrania y las aflicciones con Rusia país
que probé en gran medida de gas natural
al viejo continente sale vamos entonces
Arturo Carranza analista y experto en
temas energéticos actualmente es
director de proyectos de energía en Axa
consultores Gracias Arturo por estar con
nosotros esta mañana de martes en
directo América hablemos entonces de
esta implementación de la energía
nuclear los retos las consecuencias que
tendría la energía nuclear No ahora pues
todo derivado de la guerra en Ucrania
que es que los países de occidente sobre
todo están poniendo las miradas en este
tipo de energías
claro Raúl buenos días pues desde luego
que la energía nuclear Se presenta como
una de las opciones para resolver la
crisis energética a nivel internacional
y de manera particular la crisis
energética que vive Europa en los
últimos años la tecnología nuclear ha
avanzada avanzado de manera formidable
en temas que antes preocupaban de manera
precisa me refiero sobre todo al tema
del manejo de los desechos y al costo de
las inversiones necesarias para poder
desarrollar una central nuclear Raúl y
en este sentido creo que muchos países
hoy en día están retomando sus planes
para relanzar la energía nuclear y
disminuir gradualmente a la dependencia
de otros combustibles
fósiles de manera particular concluiría
este comentario Raúl diciéndote que una
de las premisas básicas hoy en día tiene
que ver con la necesidad de diversificar
la matriz energética los países no
pueden depender exclusivamente de una
tecnología y por eso la energía nuclear
en este sentido adquiere un nuevo
protagonismo hablabas también de un caso
Pues bien importante el comentario que
decías a Arturo de los desechos que
genera esta energía nuclear esto también
de cara digamos a las energías
renovables a las energías verdes también
que los países que están poniendo sus
esfuerzos para también dejar de generar
huella de carbono para no incrementar no
el cambio climático está energía nuclear
es eso es sostenible o cómo se puede
hacer para que esta energía sea
sostenible
No desde luego que es sostenible de Cara
a la crisis climática que está viviendo
el mundo como te comentaba los países ya
no pueden depender exclusivamente de una
tecnología hoy en día a nivel
internacional los países dependen
principalmente en promedio de los
combustibles fósiles hablo del petróleo
del gas natural y del Carbón pero en
este sentido y conforme las emisiones
contaminantes han ocasionado estragos en
el clima en todo el mundo los países
voltean a otras opciones la energía
nuclear una vez que las centrales
nucleares son construidas es
razonablemente económica Los costos de
operación de una central nuclear son
este relativamente bajos y se presenta
como una alternativa interesante para
poder desprenderse de los combustibles
fósiles pero en esta misma tesitura en
los países también hay que apostarle y
lo están haciendo de manera sólida las
energías renovables eólica y
principalmente como te comentaba la
ecuación tiene que pasar por la
diversificación combustibles fósiles y
apostarle de manera gradual y y
constante a las energías renovables y a
energías limpias como la nuclear también
es sigamos en ese tema de la energía
nuclear Arturo y yo lo quería preguntar
era cómo funciona digamos la energía
nuclear para darle energía a un país
porque mucho Estamos hablando de eso
pero pongamos un poco en contexto a
nuestra audiencia internacional como una
central nuclear provee de energía a un
país a una población una ciudad
Pues el insulto principal de la energía
nuclear es el uranio y su transformación
requiere un proceso tecnológico
relativamente avanzado que a partir de
este proceso se puede generar
electricidad tiene que ser un proceso
altamente cuidadoso para no poder para
para evitar este digamos accidentes en
su mujer en su manipulación en en su
procesamiento
En todo caso me gustaría también
comentarte Raúl que uno de los
principales
retos tiene que ver con la construcción
de las centrales nucleares son proyectos
impresionantes en cuanto a las
inversiones necesarias para poder
construir una central nuclear después
Este Al momento de que ya está
construida los Los costos de la
generación eléctrica como te comentaba
son razonablemente bajos la operación es
baja el mantenimiento de lugares donde
se procesa el uranio sin embargo tiene
que ser constante y en algunos casos
resulta elevado de suerte tal que a la
larga creo que los inversionistas han
constatado porque son proyectos
realmente fiables constantes atractivos
a nivel internacional
Arturo Ya digamos para finalizar un país
se puede sostener energéticamente
hablando solamente de la energía eólica
solar y nuclear digamos hasta cuándo
vamos a tener que depender nosotros
nuestra sociedad actual de los
hidrocarburos no para dejar ya los
combustibles fósiles a un lado y pasar a
estas nuevas energías
claro tenemos dos incentivos para
acelerar la transición energética el
primero de ellos tiene que ver con la
guerra entre Rusia y Ucrania creo que lo
que las consecuencias de esta guerra han
generado conciencia con la necesidad de
no depender exclusivamente
de un proveedor de energía hablo en el
caso particular de Europa Europa
ha tomado conciencia de la necesidad de
diversificar sus fuentes de energía no
depender exclusivamente de Europa el
segundo caso como te comentaba tiene que
ver con la crisis climática global este
desde mi punto de vista es el incentivo
más relevante para acelerar la
transición energética los países sobre
todo en Europa están tomando decisiones
muy importantes para impulsar nuevas
tecnologías la nuclear es una de ellas
Alemania Francia están
tomando la el liderazgo en este tipo de
energías también se está a nivel global
las energías renovables en todo el mundo
creo que hacia allá está apuntando las
energías renovables Son son el presente
y el futuro del planeta pero el tema es
Cómo se debe avanzar para depender
exclusivamente de estas tecnologías y
desde mi punto de vista es un avance
gradual y constante